okay um
those business decisions are being made
15 years ago another business decision
was made it came up during our draft of
the all-time best
nfl or most memorable whatever it was
business decisions eli manning making a
power play with no leverage he had no
john elway leverage that i'll go play
baseball he had the leverage of nothing
i don't want to play for you
then san diego chargers i want to play
for somebody else chargers draft him the
giants draft phillip rivers they do the
flip-flop those great pictures awkward
pictures of eli with just like this
dopey look on his face holding up the
jersey right the san diego chargers hat
but here's the thing
you know we talk so much about antonio
brown giving players more power by what
he did this year
when will another incoming player and
it's got to be a quarterback to pull it
off yes because you want your
quarterback to be all in right if your
quarterback's not all in you shouldn't
want it yep if a team holds a first pick
let's say kyler murray wanted nothing to
do with the cardinals and the cardinals
were all over him let's take josh rosen
out of the mix the cardinals want him he
doesn't want to play for the cardinals
when is somebody going to be in that
position and say i don't want to play
for you now maybe there are some
discussions behind the scenes what's
wrong with coming out and saying hey
look
i i understand there's a draft here but
let me tell you here's who i want to
play for anybody else don't bother right
i can't wait for somebody to do that now
you got to be one of the top prospects
yeah definitely you got to be wired a
certain way right but why not why not
come out i'd love that i i would
absolutely love it if somebody said and
i thought kyle murray would do it
because he could say i'll play baseball
instead yeah i don't think he's gonna do
it but i hope that there is a guy who
does it and it becomes an option for the
top prospects so they can pick where
they're going to play i still don't like
the guys get picked where they're going
to play i think the players should have
more of a role in where they end up yeah
well i mean you know to to the topic
like eli manning yeah that was a special
situation that was a big time move john
elway he did the same thing it is kind
of crazy that we don't see it more often
i guess what i would go with the eli
manning situation too you know there's
not as many people or usually guys
coming out in the draft don't have the
you know connections the bloodlines the
mannings have the overall feel and
knowledge in the nfl to make some of
those decisions to even know that the
charters were a team
right that's what i mean like you know
hey peyton's in the league archie was
around the league for a long long time
so they understood there was aspects of
the charges that they did not like but i
think for the most part yeah a lot of
these guys didn't have fathers that
played in the nfl or a bigger brother
that are playing in the nfl and they
don't know some of the inner workings or
the dysfunctions that some teams have
compared to the others probably the main
reason i would think that doesn't happen
but i mean it is amazing it's been that
long that it's happened
it's kind of shocking like i thought of
like carson palmer too like i wonder if
he thought about that with the bengals
uh at least maybe you know drawing a
line in the sand he eventually did he
did eventually right so that's why my
mind went there but we've heard nothing
of the sort since since eli manning of
anybody dabbling in this and i've had a
thought here and at the risk of agreeing
with richard sherman as it relates to
players representing themselves and i
don't believe that's the case but there
is one inherent problem with the fee
based percentage or the percentage-based
fee because if you are representing a
guy and you get paid solely based upon
how much money they get your incentive
is to get them drafted as high as
possible regardless of what team it is
so if the team with the number one pick
wants your guy
you want your guy to go there even if he
doesn't so even if you know some things
this is where the conflict of interest
arises right even if you know some
things because you've been doing it for
30 years and you've heard like
it's very dysfunctional there right yeah
but you know i i'm i i'll have a client
who was the first overall pick exactly
and i get three from a bigger contract
and you know so that that temptation
could be there if it's a
percentage-based fee
to not intervene the way that archie
manning most likely intervened and said
or peyton intervened and said hey eli
you won't want anything to do very good
with the chargers very good point maybe
that's one of the reasons why it doesn't
happen right right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports